let's go next to
a chase from new hampshire you're on the
air
um hi so i actually did have a question
about um
i forgot sorry okay that
sorry oh actually uh you should pick uh
live free from what
next i'm sorry but up he has a question
okay
a chase from new hampshire blacklisted
but i mean i'll try it we usually i
usually don't go to anyone who doesn't
have like a real name listed
but um let's try it let's go
to live free from washington who somehow
is already unmuted what's going on with
that
oh i'm one of your mods david what's up
you can unmute yourself that sounds like
too much power
it's too much power yeah what's going on
um
well i wanted to ask you a question
sorry i'm laughing
chase uh i wanted to ask you the same
question that i asked the consul general
and uh and uh from the canadian embassy
in seattle
well i can't imagine that we have the
same background and expertise but i will
try
i wanted to ask what you thought of the
north american union if you're familiar
with the concept
the north american union is this between
canada the u.s and maybe mexico
sir whoa you just cut out hold on what
was that did you say yes
i did oh what would be the it would be a
union an economic union
what what exactly are the details it
would be an economic union
in addition to a political union uh
think of like the european union but a
more federated state
i mean without knowing you know i would
the way i would think about it would be
i would want to hear what are the
parameters of the union
and what did do solid economic analyses
say
would be the impact just in a vacuum
it's hard to say
it's a good idea or it's a bad idea i
don't know
i i wouldn't wait would the idea be to
uh what would the point of it be would
it be to
um negotiate in a particular way to
align wages i mean
you know i'm just unsure what the what
the point would be
uh well my idea at least would be the
utilization of transfer families to
levelize like the total economic
capacity of these different regions uh
bring up the standard of living in
different regions have a larger
organizational capacity to like organize
against other blocks of countries or
regions
yeah especially as we move forward uh
that'd be my general kind of idea
i would evaluate it in the context of
geopolitics knowing
with china and russia as the two other
big superpowers with
you know india nigeria as a growing
power
uh the i i would think about it more in
terms of what it would do
geopolitically from the standpoint of
american interests now if you want to
say would it be better for canada
or mexico those are different
calculations
but i would want to see an economic
analysis that would look at it from what
does it mean for the united states in a
geopolitical context
geopolitics is definitely the first lens
which i look at this through i mean the
same thing with ttp and ttip
um you know looking at i mean containing
is probably the wrong word but
utilizing trade mechanisms to limit the
expansion of china's influence you know
and other factors it's completely
conceivable
that economists would look at it and say
that's a good idea
i think it's basically an academic
question because you and i probably
both would agree that's this isn't going
to happen well it's an academic question
definitely in the next 50 years or so
but i you know thinking
broader and beyond that i i yeah i would
ironically call myself a globalist and
think it's a good idea
and you're not saying you're not using
that as code for jewish as money right
now
no like globalization
of right sorry people are laughing at me
you're not saying i'm
jewish you're saying you are actually a
globalist yes no i'm saying i'm actually
a globe
goddess all right very good i appreciate
the call
all right you have a good day david all
right rescuing the abortive call from
chase from new hampshire
that is going to do it for today i'm
sorry i wasn't able to get to everybody
but we will take
calls again if i have anything to say
about it we'll take a quick break
and be right back after this